When a story unfolds in the real world that
seems like a movie come to life, Hollywood
studios don't waste time in adapting it.
But not every movie based on a true story
is clearly advertised as one, which means
some stories that seem too strange, too hard
to believe, or just too well-hidden to be
based on fact slip by audiences.
Let us know if we missed any in the comments
below!
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Movies You Won't
Believe Are Based On Real Stories.
Nacho Libre (Paramount Pictures)
That's right, the movie that cast Jack Black
as a Mexican priest entering the world of
Lucha Libre to support local orphans actually
happened.
The movie is based on the life of Sergio Gutiérrez
Benítez, a priest in Texcoco Mexico who learned
just how much money it took to care for over
200 orphans.
Inspired by movies he had seen that showed
completely fictional priests who wrestled
to raise money, Benitez did it for real, taking
the name of Fray Tormenta - Friar Storm.
He kept his dayjob a secret for years, but
when a rival revealed Friar Storm was a priest
in disguise, the money and donations began
to roll in - a twist that had the priest wishing
he'd let it slip from the start.
Rocky (United Artists)
Everyone knows the story of the small-time
boxer who finds the heart to take on the heavyweight
champ, but Rocky isn't as original a story
as you might think.
Early on, Sylvester admitted that he started
writing the movie's script after seeing a
15-round fight between heavyweight champ Muhammad
Ali and Chuck Wepner, a boxer who'd been written
off, forced to work as a bouncer while he
trained.
Since Rocky's opponent Apollo Creed was also
based on Ali, Wepner would eventually sue
Stallone in 2006 for stealing his life's story.
The lawsuit was settled out of court, but
the theft didn't stop there.
For research, the production team had also
sought out Muhammad Ali's greatest opponent,
Joe Frazier, who makes a cameo in the film.
Rocky punching sides of meat and running the
steps of the Philadelphia Museum of Art?
Both taken from Frazier's own life without
giving any credit - a fact that the former
heavyweight champ is still sore about.
Indiana Jones (Paramount)
We explained in an earlier video how Indiana
Jones was based on the 1954 movie Secret of
the Incas, but both characters owe their origin
to a real life explorer.
Hiram Bingham ("High-rum Bing-um") was just
36 years old when he realized teaching history
and politics at Harvard, then Yale wasn't
enough to keep him busy, and organized a search
for the lost capitol of the Incas based mainly
on curiosity.
Relying on centuries-old books and local guides,
his search would lead him to the ruins of
Macchu Picchu, a mountaintop city that had
been lost to South American history.
The site was a major breakthrough, and his
book became a bestseller when it released
just 6 years before Charlton Heston played
a rougher version of the adventurer, with
Indy following decades later.
A Nightmare on Elm Street (New Line Cinema)
No, there's no documented proof of a child
murderer returning from the dead to kill teenagers
in their sleep.
But the inspiration for Freddy Krueger is
realer than fans would think.
Director Wes Craven has explained that the
story began when he read multiple accounts
of Cambodian immigrants dying under strange
circumstances.
In the case of one family having settled in
Los Angeles, things were fine until their
young son began refusing to sleep, convinced
that if he did, an unseen terror was going
to kill him.
After staying awake for days and hiding coffeemakers
in his room, he succumbed to sleep.
Hours later, they heard him screaming in terror,
and found him dead in his own bed.
Craven let his imagination run wild, and A
Nightmare on Elm Street was born.
300 (Warner Bros.)
Zack Snyder's vision of ancient Spartan warriors
may be based on Frank Miller's comic, but
viewers who loved 300's intense action and
badass battles may not know just how accurate
the movie actually is.
Sure, there weren't any mutants or magical
beasts at the battle of Thermopylae, but the
Spartans really were famous throughout the
ancient world for their skills at delivering
one-liners.
The soldiers being happy for the shade offered
by storms of arrows fits with actual historical
accounts, along with their response to being
commanded to lay down their arms.
King Leonidas may not have actually screamed,
"This is Sparta", but the other lines are
still used as mottos in the Greek army to
this day.
Plus, he really did throw Persian emissaries
down as well.
Fury (Columbia Pictures)
The story of star Brad Pitt's tank crew making
a glorious stand in World War II Germany isn't
based on a single crew, since the final product
is too poetic to be true.
But director David Ayer pulled from multiple
true stories to keep Fury accurate.
Take the real world war hero Audie Murphy,
who mounted the machine gun atop a burned
out tank to singlehandedly hold off a German
assault, just like the movie's heroes.
Brad Pitt's character is even named after
American tank commander Lafayette "War Daddy"
Pool, who racked up a total of 258 armoured
vehicle and mobile gun kills in just 3 months.
If that wasn't enough, Ayer based the movie's
climax around the story told by American soldiers
of a single recruit found alive in a burned
out tank smack in the middle of a country
crossroad, surrounded by dozens of enemy dead.
Heat (Warner Bros.)
Most movie buffs will tell you that Michael
Mann's Heat is based on the real-world Bank
of America shootout in 1997, when gunmen overwhelmed
LAPD officers with assault rifles and body
armor.
But it isn't just the action scenes that were
inspired by the real world.
The director's friend Chuck Adamson, a former
Chicago police officer gets some of the credit
for the movie's main rivalry.
Apparently, Adamson really did face off with
a career thief name McCauley - De Niro's character
- and the pair really did sit down for a heated
cup of coffee while one was chasing the other.
In the end, McCauley fled a robbery knowing
he was trapped, was chased down, then shot
and killed by Adamson, just as the movie shows.
The Hunt For Red October (Paramount)
Tom Clancy's CIA hero has gone through some
crazy adventures, but one Jack Ryan movie
was based on more than imagination.
In The Hunt For Red October, the commander
of a Soviet nuclear submarine flees for America,
looking to defect while his authorities set
out to sink his sub instead.
Total fiction, right?
Wrong.
Clancy based his story on Captain Valery Sablin,
who along with loyal crew, stole a destroyer
called The Sentry.
Soviet forces would soon sink the ship, claiming
Sablin was looking to flee to the West.
It was only after Clancy published his book
that the true story came out: Sablin was looking
to attack Soviet leadership, and spark an
even more communistic revolution.
So the true story of Red October... wasn't
really true at all?
Star Wars (Disney/Lucasfilm)
George Lucas wasn't trying to hide the role
Nazi Germany played on his space epic, naming
his "stormtroopers" after Germany's own special
attack forces.
Star Wars wasn't ABOUT Nazi Germany, but the
influences are clear.
The uniforms of the Empire are drawn from
history, as is the alliance - led by American
heroes - who overthrew the old order.
The space battles were based on real footage
of aerial dogfights, the famous "Kessel Run"
is based on a German military term, while
the planet Hoth is named for a German general
who served on the frozen Russian front.
The first movie's finale is even modeled after
German propaganda films, but the prequels
went even further, showing how the Emperor
began as a Chancellor, just as Adolf Hitler
did.
Director J.J. Abrams has even admitted that
when the writers wondered what would have
happened if the Nazis regrouped after losing
the war, the First Order, the villains of
the next Star Wars trilogy were born.
The Shining (Warner Bros.)
Stanley Kubrick's classic horror movie, just
like the Stephen King novel it's based on,
is beyond famous.
But horror fans would be surprised to know
it wasn't completely fiction.
In a time when the author would sometimes
feel genuine anger towards his own children,
King and his wife spent a night at the Stanley
Hotel in Colorado.
As the only guests near the end of the season,
the couple walked down long, empty hallways,
stayed in the haunted Room 217, and even shared
a quiet drink with the hotel's only bartender.
The moments all made it into the book, but
it wasn't until King woke from a nightmare,
seeing his son running in terror through the
hotel that The Shining was born, with the
basic plot decided before King headed back
to bed.
Those are the films based on actual events
and people that we couldn't believe, but what
are your favorites?
Be sure to name them in the comments, and
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one!